well we still don't know where the
coronavirus came from originally in
Wuhan anyone who tells you where certain
of that is lying to you but many people
believe it could have originated in the
wet market in Wuhan that's a place where
consumers buy the meat of wild animals
to eat including bats wild animal wet
markets have long been recognized as a
major pandemic threat as Koerner virus
spread china announced it would crack
down on them obviously but it looks like
the crackdown didn't last long according
to Daily Mail across China wet markets
are reopening and selling the same
animals they did before in the city of
guilin dogs and cats dogs and cats are
both for sale as food in Tuan guan a
stand selling traditional Chinese
medicines advertises things like lizards
scorpions and yes bats again we have
known for more than a decade that wet
markets are a disease time bomb this is
not the first virus to emanate from them
but it looks like even after a global
crisis China continues to threaten the
rest of us with wet markets